[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's a damon
in the sack in this video we're breaking
down matt smith's character in house of
the dragon set up to be one of the major
antagonists slash anti-heroes damon has
a long and storied history in the source
material that means we're going to get
some major moments in the show bull
spoilers ahead and with us covering the
entire character's history we will be
going over both his life and death as
well as what happened to those around
him this means that the show may get
ruined for you if you go forward but
we'd massively appreciate the thumbs up
and also make sure you subscribe for
breakdowns like this every day with that
all out the way huge thank you for
clicking this now let's get into our
house of the dragon breakdown
[Music]
okay so damon first came to prominence
during chapter 12 of fire and blood
tidal layers of the dragon it recounts
all the events of the show including all
its characters early on damon is
introduced as the heir to king viserys
but as we see in the show this gets
passed over to his daughter damon was
the second son of prince balon targaryen
and his wife alyssa a daemon in the book
is described as being fair and dashing
however he also hides a sadistic side to
him that makes him very dangerous an
early paragraph on the character
describes him as being someone who cut
the hands off of pickpockets and along
with this he also slipped the noses of
thieves damon took pleasure from pain
and when he wasn't causing misery he was
hanging out in the brothel with his side
chick misery or missouri she she gets
the nickname misery basically because of
her reputation and you can see how the
two were attracted to each other now
they both fell in love and mazaria ended
up becoming pregnant but we'll talk
about this more as we get further into
the video the whole thing became a bit
of an entanglement as damon actually
married lady ria in order to have some
allegiances between the family and those
at runestone damon absolutely hated her
and he called her the bronze [ __ ] with
it being purely just a marriage that was
based on status he actually asked his
brother if he could renege on it but
viserys refused and thus the wedding
still went ahead now he ended up
supporting viserys in his ascension as
this would allow him to become the next
in line at the celebration at maidenpool
he ended up riding into the tournament
as arrogant as ever however he was
bested by kristin cole which echoes what
we see in the first episode of the
series it did change the timeline of a
bittier with a tournament originally
happening for the ascension of viserys
whereas here it's for the birth of his
son bailin now as we hear in the opening
episode damon had many jobs the first
being the master of coin he only did
this for a year and it's during this
time that he made an enemy of otto
hightower as hand of the king otto
convinced viserys to remove him from the
position and he was then appointed as
the commander of the city watch whereas
the governing coin job had bored him he
absolutely loved this new role because
it allowed him to carry out murder under
the guise of law and order he ruled with
passion and ferocity and quickly became
a highly regarded figure amongst the
city watch which backfired on otto he
was hoping that this would remove him
from a position of true power but he now
had two thousand men who all loyally
served him crime fell under his reign
and he ended up giving every god a
golden cloak which created the idea that
they were truly above the peasants damon
vastly sought the role as heir to the
throne and as we saw in the show this
was taken away from him after baylen's
death now in the book and series he
coined the term air for a day and damon
truly believed that this was a higher
power clearing the way for him to ascend
becerras was pretty annoyed by this
though and he then announced rhaenyra as
the official heir damon ended up leaving
with mazaria and because of this he
didn't attend his ceremony in the red
keep and from here the pair flew to
dragonstone which is where she felt
pregnant he also gave her a dragon egg
as well which was supposed to symbolize
the birth of a new child in the family
typically these would be placed in the
crib alongside the baby and they were
meant to show connection to the royal
family only thing is damon actually took
the one that was meant for bailin which
added further insult to injury now
viserysen commanded that he returned the
egg and he also said he had to go back
to rio in the vale daemon ended up
abiding by this and he sent mazaria away
to lies on this journey she ended up
losing their child which made damon
fully start to turn against his brother
he then made an allegiance with corliss
and was declared king of the stepstones
and narrow sea it didn't last too long
though and damon became bored with this
and he returned home during which time
he buried the hatchet with his brother
he gave up his kingdom and he ended up
sitting on the small council once more
and whilst all this was going on viserys
had married alison and together the pair
had kids which meant that he was now
further down the line thus he started to
really sink his claws into rhaenyra and
the pair allegedly slept together
according to the book with it just being
texts they sort of have two takes on it
with one tale saying that rhaenyra
simply said she loved him whilst the
character mushroom said he taught her
how to seduce champions rhaenyra
apparently approached kristin cole but
he rejected her and many told viceroys
that he should execute his brother for
treason but instead he just exiled him
shortly after this ria fell from a horse
and died which meant that he could claim
the runestone for himself he was however
rejected by the house and thus he turned
his eyes to another kingdom namely house
valerian he asked lord corliss for his
daughter's hand in marriage but she was
promised to the son of a sea lord damon
wouldn't let this get in the way though
and he killed him and then married the
girl now due to it not being
pre-approved by the king the pair then
left for essos and they ended up having
two twin daughters damon wrote to his
brother asking if the pair could receive
a royal blessing and as he believed that
fatherhood had changed him he allowed
them to attend his wife lana fell
pregnant again but she died in
childbirth and this sent damon off the
deep end even further than before
mysterious fires started spring up which
he was suspected for and he once more
continued on his quest for power
unbeknownst to king viserys he married
his daughter rhaenyra in secret and it
was believed that damon also killed her
previous husband to create an opening
for him the bear had two sons prince
aegon and also viserys it gets confusing
lots of people called pacerus now at one
point there was a ton of people in line
for the throne and when viserys died of
an illness the dance of the dragons
began this is basically used as a term
for when everyone fighted out for the
throne and it led to a lot of bloodshed
it also saw the blacks and greens come
to prominence which were two sides that
showed support for the people that they
believed should be next on the throne
alicent was prominent in the greens and
she pushed the idea that her son aegon
was the true heir whilst the black
supported rhaenyra and daemon the latter
had another daughter who was stillborn
with the blame for this being placed on
the greens slowly daemon called together
the houses that hadn't pledged loyalty
to them and he tried to gain a vast
majority the crown was smuggled out of
the capital under daemon's command and
it was then placed on his wife's head
from here on out he led several attacks
on the greens and there was lots of
infighting within the family due to the
targaryens gaining allegiances with both
sides aegon was also announced as the
king and the family went to war with
itself now due to them all possessing
dragons the entire landscape ended up
becoming a hellscape covered in ash
damian also started to have an affair
with a woman called nettles my zero
popped up out of nowhere and told
rhaenyra about this and she ended up
ordering the death of nettles damon
found out about this in advance and he
sent her away on his ship before
announcing his own departure he knew it
wouldn't be long before he was found
though and eventually he was tracked by
the character eamonn who arrived on his
dragon veigar they battled with damon
and karaxis which led to them all
apparently dying in the air damon ended
up jumping from his dragon karaxis to
veigar and he killed both which caused
them to plummet into like below them
whilst eamon's body was recovered though
demons never was and though it was
thought he died you never bloody know
anyway that's everything you need to
know about the character and his
apparent full life let me know below
what elements of this that you want to
see in the show and i hope as always
that you enjoyed the video we are
running competition right now and giving
away three copies of top gun maverick on
the 15th of september and all you have
to do to be on the chance of winning is
like the video make sure you subscribe
with notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character you pick the comments at
random at the end of the month and the
winners of the last one are on screen
right now so that's you then message me
on twitter at heavy spoilers you want
some emails to watch that makes you
check out our breakdown of the first
episode which will be linked on screen
right now we go over all the major
characters in it the hidden details as
well and how it's all setting things up
for the future hopefully i see you over
there right after this but if not enjoy
the rest of your week take care peace